Here's a brief look at imaging
with fluorescing material.
The wonderful thing
about our photography
is that we can image at
very long shutter speeds.
This particular image
was taken at four seconds
and I was on a tripod.
So, we can do that when we
have the right equipment.
You're looking at
a series of vials
that contain nano crystals,
and I am exciting it
with ultraviolet lamps.
Here is another image
that I'm not crazy about.
That's the image
that the researchers
would have preferred.
I then went back
and started playing
with the cuvettes with all these
cadmium selenide nanocrystals.
I placed it in
this order and then
I made it a little more random.
You're not gonna do
this all the time,
but happens that this particular
material was screaming
to be played with, and, it
was really important research
about quantum dots.
In these next two
images, here's one
that was taken under UV
light because these gels
in the petri dishes
are also fluorescent
(different wavelengths, of
course, from the previous one.)
And here it is with fluorescing,
with UV light, and, room light.
I had a combination
of both on these.
And here's another example
of those quantum dots.
This time they were
infused into plastic.
Here is a purely UV
illuminated image,
and, once again, I decided to
turn on some available light,
and it's like a sort
of a combination
of using the UV lamp
and available lamp
light in the lab.